you pack your bags and you're ready to  make a new country what next without  land a country is just an idea you'll  need to secure some space for your  nation you might purchase an island or  if you're on a budget you may consider  transforming your current home into a  country within a country every nation  has at least a few permanent residents  if you're unable to find anybody willing  to emigrate you may consider inviting  your friends and family to do desire  sovereignty and order you'll need some  rules any laws will do but you may want  to borrow from other countries with all  of the technicalities complete it's time  for the fun part  your new nation will need a catchy name  and maybe a flag  finally it's time to tell the world that  you're exist is the internet or to Mouse  and advertising just by the word and  that's really all there is to it enjoy  your new nation